hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Ryan
Wright and welcome to the Ryan Wright
show no this is Jerry today a lot of
people have been asking that we talk
about this we're gonna talk about one of
the most important things nan has ever
seen Ben Affleck in the Batman suit I
love how everyone it was at first like
[ __ ] Ben Affleck now that this pictures
out people like this is gonna be awesome
forgive me but that's sort of how the
blogosphere works is like there's news
[ __ ] at news then you know months go
by and then they're like alright there's
a picture alright I you know I had faith
in him um I was able to vision it and
this is what it comes out like there is
a certain short-term memory it seems in
popular culture yeah people are freaking
out about I mean like let's look at it
right now like it's a cool [ __ ]
picture for shirts very moody yeah and
like I love the look of a Batmobile
because it kind of has a cross between
what we saw in like the Tim Burton
version and the nolan version and the
suit even itself has a cross between
that it does have like a frank miller
vibe about it for sure especially with
the short ears as somebody pointed out
to me that oh yeah they are really tiny
ears no the suit the costume was cool i
honestly like to see more than the dark
knight suit it's it's it's different it
has more of a comic-book strike to it it
does feel a little more comic book it's
a little less you know military I just
realized I was gonna bag on me from
wearing this Superman shirt but I
wouldn't my bad Matrix movie called
Batman vs Superman technically you will
always be halfway in the right yes
exactly I mean it's in black and white
which I it's just cool but it's same
time like I kind of wish we had a color
picture just a little tiny bit oh I
think that's the point because now
they're diggities because it's a more
comic book universe you know it's like
they redesigned it to a degree the
Superman suit and now it's like oh
what's gonna be the color scheme and
what they're gonna be the sort of
in-your-face elements of the Batman suit
so there's still it this is like their
way of giving you a tease without giving
you all of it we have three awesome
Batman films and then we get one Man of
Steel movie once Superman film and then
all we're psyched about is Batman if it
seems like Batman is a character that's
a lot easier to make very like able to
sink your teeth into and and really sort
of interesting and conflicted and it
seems like Superman you got to work a
little harder at that but Superman
you're more it admiration
of his abilities as opposed to like that
man who's really had to like train and
stuff like that he's got a really
haunted dark past and everything I've
read The Dark Knight Returns and you do
see how Batman does take on Superman and
it's pretty [ __ ] cool actually man if
you haven't read it yet do something
with your life and [ __ ] read it what's
wrong with you yeah sorry okay and
staring at walls it's exciting to see
how they'll do this in a realistic world
of how can they pull off a believable
story with Batman taking on Superman you
know now you're in this weird area this
weird middle ground between you know
more fantastical comic-book movies and
more grounded kind of moving and it
seems like this one's trying to meet
somewhere in the middle so I'm
interested to see how they'll make that
work right now I want to tell you how
this picture makes me feel I feel dark I
feel moody it's definitely I feel a
little depressed you do get a lot out of
this oh this is real [ __ ] muscles I
don't know I mean what does he like
because I heard he got buff as [ __ ] for
this role the first time I saw this
picture I didn't quite think it was I
can't tell if it's a photograph or or or
some kind of composite of an actual
picture and then photoshopping and
effects and stuff so I don't know not
gonna lie it's [ __ ] cool the more I
look at it the more I'm like this is bad
that's a great picture I mean the
Batmobile actually is a lot more Krishna
land than I thought it would be really
it looks more Tim Burton eating me know
we're on two sides of a fence oh then
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] all those who disagree
with me it doesn't it looks less like a
car and more still like a military
vehicle you know lots of plates and
armor like it doesn't look like a bat
necessarily having Batman be more of a
comic book type of character in this
then the Nolan trilogy sort of made him
like it makes sense to like yeah this
savage Steve this one pitcher I'm like I
can totally see how a Batman and
Superman movie will work like it just
looks [ __ ] sweet look at it man I'm
interested to see if they're gonna
release any Wonder Woman stuff oh I am
one of those people has a problem with
that
what Wonder Woman in this well it does
feel a little bit like the cramming to
get Justice League together yeah it's
like dude give it some time this is
Batman and Superman colliding let's not
have a diss
your action in the film you know what I
mean well I mean that's the thing that
seems to be troublesome with superhero
movies now in general is like everything
is the greatest battle and more
characters and and the more of these we
get on a more consistent basis the
bigger and bigger and bigger they have
to be I hope this doesn't fall into that
pit what I love about like what's going
on with a DC world right now is you have
the Nolan trilogy right and then now
you're getting this show called Gotham
which is about you know when when he was
just like loot detective Gordon then
lieutenant dick Commissioner how's it go
what are the rankings again I don't know
yeah whatever and you got a young Batman
and stuff so you kind of get you know a
real prequel about it and then you got
this version where he's supposed to be a
little bit older and more tired as he
looks here I don't want to work anymore
what's good about this picture is it
does make you go this looks like it's
going to be different I'm glad we came
together to talk about this photo
yeah well thank you guys if you knew the
channel subscribe dude I don't care what
Ben Affleck does with this movie that
will always be the Batman we remember
clarity he must ever know different than
George Clooney being like I'm George
Clooney in a mess but you know what
saved it do you know what killed the
dinosaurs the Ice Age cool partying go
down chill freeze shoutout time people
Josef boner is going on man how's your
erection do honor
it's boner I'm sure he didn't get that
all throughout his jaw and hidden he
deserved it I'm kidding man I'm kidding
what he said was they I probably did get
a bad childhood cuz he wants to make his
other friends jealous is what he said so
guess what boner you got the best boner
out there and I know it only a man as
confident as you would call himself
Joseph the man who helped take care of
Christ and boner meaning and only only
someone who makes as many dick
references as you would be able to make
an assessment like that on cross
cyberspace hey you know who else we
should shout out to who
McGraw mow John William I don't know how
to say that oh he's from Hong Kong so
probably not with that Spanish
inflection hey I
I know a guy from Hong Kong his name is
Jackie Chan do you know him yeah you
know what's he like oh yeah that sounds
like what Jackie Chan would be like
anyway McGraw no it sounds like me
Krueger McGraw though John William
you're the most American sounding Hong
Kong guy Tyler Mendes Tyler hey you
wanted a shout-out buddy so you know
what man we're gonna get creative here
we are
Tyler kind of reminds me you know I'm
gonna write you a rap song right here
right now Tyler when you [ __ ] a girl her
[ __ ] gets out on fire
your feet are as hairy as hobbit from
the Shire you can tell the truth but
you're one hell of a liar
people see Joseph boner and they admire
oh cool that's heavy Tyler Mendes